[Music]
what we say in pornography is so much
about men controlling and dominating and
hurting women men are consuming huge
quantities of pornography they have no
idea where it comes from at all they
have no interest or concern about the
performers well I think people that
watch it presume that it's acting they
presume that people are performing
something to is script something that's
been choreographed and that if they can
go to the cinema and watch a violent
movie where people are being paid to act
then it isn't any different in
pornography I think it's just a getter
cruise that people give to themselves
because they want to see pretty vicious
things being done to women think
something that's really difficult for us
to get our heads around as ethical
people if we call ourselves that is that
desire is amoral now it's not immoral
but we might fantasize about things that
we've never have we never dream of doing
in real life and so pornography tends to
fill that void and if you could
guarantee that that person wasn't harmed
in the process and is it wrong to want
to watch that
I think desire has to be morally right
if we're not putting our desires to the
test of our morals then what is even the
point of having morals right I do firmly
believe that there are ways of
protecting all performers involved in
the porn industry and I think it's
really important to say that men can
also be vulnerable to exploitation as
well as women even if we see men
performing dominant acts and always been
on top so to speak in the industry we
know that sometimes they're forced or
encouraged to take viagra way past the
point of comfort the nature of sexism is
that it does come down harder on women a
woman's career is shorter the kind of
act that a woman has to do in
pornography to collect the big box like
you are going to age out of pornography
a very young age and for women that
means doing stuff that is tougher and
tougher on your body from the
spective someone that's been a sex
worker and done sex sexual things with
people that I didn't know didn't
necessarily like or find attractive but
that they were paying me to do those
things with them I would say that in
those situations I was happy to take the
money because it was preferable to lots
of other kinds of work and I was often
you know I was treated really well by
and large I everything we did was
consensual I said the terms of it so I
don't think sex is the same for everyone
the levels of trauma among women who
sold sex are really really high the
level of exposure to other kinds of
violence are really really high and
that's true whether they're selling sex
on a person-to-person basis or whether
they're selling sex as part of
pornography
you know ten years ago we didn't have a
discussion about ethical porn today we
do today there are numerous places you
can go on the internet to find it
I think ethical porn and the stuff
that's produced by women for women and
by LGBT performers and producers proves
that there's another way to make the
material it's a really small coterie of
people who are trying to produce ethical
porn the fact that they exist isn't
making a difference to the rest of the
industry you know if I keep my own hens
that is not going to change the egg
industry as a whole we should be really
championing the people that are trying
to do something better and I don't think
it is just like keeping your own hens
it's a grassroots movement at the moment
but with momentum and consumer pressure
it can grow thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to recieve notifications for new videos
see you again soon